this they made the fish heavier yeah he
put weights in it we got weights in
[Laughter]
fish dude the level of anger bro yeah
can you pull up the original I got to
hear him cuss man yeah that's real is
that the cheater yeah dude is nothing
sacred look at his head down he knows
he's [__] yeah he knows he's he's a bad
person weights and fish we got weights
and
fish yeah and the way that crowd just
Riles up afterward is so good you ever
had some of these guys just pull up to
your show and you know like they don't
know who you are oh yeah and they're
always in the front yeah yeah they're
just looking like yeah yeah and you can
always like you always hit them with one
I feel like you get them with one and
they're like yeah all right yeah yeah
sometimes they'll be like miserable the
whole show and then afterwards you'll be
doing like a meet and green they like
that was really funny great sweet hook
lying in Sinker what a
Team of the Year if you believe those
who were there this is the
moment l r this is good little
commentary is help go up Anglers Jacob
ran and Chase Kaminsky leading yet
another fishing tournament your new
leaders locking it in Team of the Year
definitely Team of the Year Champions
they even headed up to take their
pictures at the lake Eerie Walley
fishing competition ready to claim
almost 30 Grand in prize money but watch
closely just moments later the events
organizer Jason fiser decides to check
the belly of one of those fish we got
weights and fish there we
go one of the best deliveries of all
time can can we watch him do that again
this guy's a superstar of course with
the fist pump afterwards I mean the
level of indignation this guy has Fisher
decides to check the belly of one of
those fish we got weights and fish there
we go come on come on
he's not having it n he's fired up man
he was raised right yeah man and he's
wide dude you you don't want to piss
this guy off exactly he's a unit he's
like bro I will punch straight through
your skull dude M calling fell in a way
only true fisherman can
godamn but Jason fiser wasn't done
investigating almost 8 lbs of lead
weights and a bunch of fresh looking
fish filets inside a feted fish
meanwhile Jake Rion still standing there
now dude the shame on it like you can't
even see his face and you can feel the
shame in his neck and cheeks you can
dude it's radiating off of it man we got
weights and fish we got weights and
fish bro for him to stand here and take
you know he's processing it all his
entire Legacy is just crumbling before
his eyes he's just reving in the final
moments of Fame before he can never show
his face at the fishing tournament ever
again I got to go back to law school
my's watching this from Heaven
yeah watching point blank what he was
thinking do you have anything to say
Jake do you have anything to say
Jake nothing so then what happens Steve
Hendrick and Brian rmer finished fourth
they couldn't believe what they were
seeing or at least almost couldn't
believe it finally we don't have to deal
with this anymore and we finally got rid
of the problem that everybody suspected
the sunburn on the guy to the right is
phenomenal is phenomenal yeah Viking
levels
red I just hope I just hope they Hammer
them turns out it's not oh the first
time ran and Kaminsky have been
suspected of cheating last year they
were disqualified from another
championship after one of them failed a
polygraph
what what
dude that was so amazing
what is a man you had to take a
polygraph after doing a fishing
tournament that's pretty insane what is
that dude what is that questionnaire did
you catch this yeah I wonder if he was
like in a deposition for like a divorce
or something and then like the fishing
guys were like hey throw in some fishing
questions in there too is that Kaminsky
that cheating that cheating son of a
[__] HED under the table man you ask
him did he catch that fish back there
and [__] did you catch that fish for
real yeah damn lawyer just slips it
clean and just um another note while
we're discussing the proceedings here
did you catch that fish for real was
that got to do with my wife though just
answer the question
question the the lawyer puts on those
like blue glasses did you catch them for
real oh we got wait some you got Whits
and fish I also feel like the polygraph
thing that's like a thing when like when
you're lying you're like did you give me
a polygraph and you never expect the
other people of the fishing commission
to be like all right let's do
it they just pull it out the closet okay
brother they're all wearing camo at the
thing I know bro I can't see anyone
right now according to reports runan
said he was innocent and got a lawyer as
for this past weekend law enforcement is
now involved oh that's so good did oh go
to jail bro shout out this is in Ohio oh
wow Ohio's Department of Natural
Resources released a statement kuah hoga
dude they take that [__] seriously like
like uh like game and nature violation
like I've I have a lot of family in
Wyoming and I had a buddy JP he got this
was years ago but he got three DUI I
think he lost his license for only a
month and then I knew another guy who
horribly got drunk and shot elk with
like an assault rifle out of season did
like five years in jail whoa wow and my
buddy was his lawyer like my dad's from
was his lawyer he's like yeah I knew he
was going down he can't kill elk out of
season wow elk out of season that's
crazy what about with a
car how much time can I do if
I yeah dude that's inally hit did you
intentionally hit that elk
no we we got him we got weights and Elk
we got weights and Elk say yeah what's
the so if they get what's like the crime
here what's the crime weights and fish
and fish put flame fish yeah dude they
were indicted for cheating attempted
Grand Theft possessing criminal tools
and the unlawful ownership of wild
animals well dude yeah cuz I guess if
you're the prize money of 30 grand
that's stealing yeah yeah yeah yeah
Grand and dude and the fact that it's
what probably over 15K so it's Grand
Theft yeah this is the greatest bank
robbery of of the last I don't know five
years wow be tough conversation with
your s yeah yo why are you in here man
weights and fish oh you the weights and
fish [__] start just starts
joking they're worse than chomos out
there this guy put weights and fish got
put weights and fish can't believe what
you've done to the [__] fishing game
you piece of [__] dude I got to hear
what this lawyer has to say sorry I'm
I'm I'm still on this story it's pretty
amazing sport where you were supposed to
be honest and for these guys to come in
and do this was just absolutely
reprehensible now we reached out to ran
I know this guy yeah we know you do yeah
dude he's he's a good you know he's like
kind of like the top UFO on the news guy
really yeah oh yeah we met him on a
plane ride to
oh good guy yeah he's a great guy back
that local
not said the two men could face felony
charges fines and possibly some prison
time guys wow wow there
is cut to these stupid City Slickers
that's these New York Elites don't get
it look down all these fishing fu yeah I
man I just want to like bet that one of
them's like hopefully there's no weights
in my suit
[Laughter]
Sushi here's weights and Sugarfish yeah
weights and Sugarfish I think sugar fish
got in trouble for uh fish swapping oh
really oh like their tuna was hbit their
halit was oh okay oh wow something else
their Toro something else their Toro was
Cod yeah
yeah